[Music]
my name is peter jessen i'm a saxophone
restorer and maker i'm situated in
copenhagen in denmark i'll walk you
through how i restore a dented 1927
soprano saxophone this saxophone is
totally out of working order it's badly
dented it's bent i'll have to take it
all apart and a lot of it is rusted
together a lot of dent has to be taken
out
[Music]
in order to make a good job on a
saxophone like this you have to take
everything apart
every part has to come off because you
can't really work on bodywork with the
whole keyboard on it
with the keyword rusted everything has
to be addressed so you strip it
completely
take all key work off
for the disassembly i use standard tools
as screwdrivers
pliers
a little bunsen burner to heat up and
boils
the springs on old instruments are often
useless they have lost all their
flexibility and strength so they have to
be clipped off or pushed out or both and
sometimes it can be really taxing
because they also are subject to rusting
in order to get a perfect functioning
instrument you have to replace all the
springs to get it really nice
here i am removing the thumb hook which
is what supports your right hand when
you carry this iphone and you play it
this is a small hook that's sorted onto
the tube for support and as it sticks
out it is often the one that gets dented
into the instrument the hook itself is
quite thick and hard and you have to
remove it to get to the tube to get the
dent out properly
[Music]
i have different tapered mandrel parts
that i can put on a threaded rod so they
will fit the exact spot inside the board
instrument and i can push out the dents
with that and make a pretty good result
rather than using a ball or something
not accurate this is a very good method
of getting the dents out precisely
[Music]
the problem with the instrument and
dents is very much where they are and
how big they are because a lot of
players play on fairly dented
instruments with no problem they're
underneath post their support mechanism
you get problems
particularly on a small instrument like
a soprano saxophone it is essential
because the tubing is very narrow and
you can't afford much discrepancy for
the airflow
certain areas of the instrument i can't
get to with the tapered mandrel parts i
have to use a dent ball and i measure up
the dent ball to fit inside the tube
where the dent is i slid it in
[Music]
and after that i slid on the next ball
then and i can use that as a hammer by
swinging the instrument up and down
so i push the first deadpool through
where the dent is and remove it that way
here i'm using a hand roller burnisher
to smooth the surface because after the
dead balls there will be slight ripples
on the surface and you can remove that
and also round the instruments if it's
got a few high points you can lower them
the critical thing about dent work is
that you cannot expand the ball of the
instrument which is an easy thing if you
slam on with a hammer or you push too
hard with a dent tool or something
because expansion of the body tube will
be stuck before which is essential for
tuning which will affect your playing
and the instrument's playability
[Music]
this saxophone is very old it's been
lying around probably for decades and
silver plate will tarnish with age
so it's very very dull
gray black looking and it's such a nice
silver finish underneath so the effort
of polishing will make an instrument
that's beautiful
on bigger instruments you might use a
polishing machine i could use one on
this but it's nicer to get into the
detail with hand polishing
[Music]
the keys have to be polished i put them
in a rag in a vise and polish it from
there and get into the corners
of every part of the key as far as you
can
[Music]
after polishing
things will turn up that you didn't
notice when the horn was
dirty and tarnished and you see slight
ripples because the polishing surface
will reflect the light much more and
here i'm smoothing out little
imperfections with a hammer
here i use a hand roller burnisher again
against a steel sickle that is fitted to
the table surface this sequel will fit
the rim of the bell and i can roll out
the dents on the bell rim
[Music]
after straightening up the dent
underneath thumb hook i fit the hook
and i paste it on the underside with a
paste which is keeping the soft sort of
flux which keeps the area clean and
helps to solve the flow once i apply the
heat
[Music]
after soldering the thumb hook on there
will be some tiny excess solder on the
sides which i remove with the polishing
knife
[Music]
after finding the pad that fits the
right key i preliminary fit it to the
key and once i'm happy with the fit i
heat up some shellac and stick it onto
the pad in order to put it back under
the key fit it again and then heat it
into place with the shellac as a binder
the pad will stay in place and it will
be a nice seal
[Music]
once all the keys are fitted you start
by putting it together
and there's a progression in how you do
this you start with the right hands
mechanism and you work your way through
the instrument and it sort of follows
logically what comes first and what
comes last
restoring a saxophone like this is long
and arduous but at the end it's very
satisfying to make life a new first
saxophone from 1927.
[Music]